[Music]
welcome to Bible answers live where
you'll get honest answers to your Bible
questions let's face it it's not always
easy to understand everything you read
in the Bible with 66 books and more than
700,000 words the Bible can generate a
lot of questions if you'd like answers
to your Bible questions you've come to
the right place now here's your host
Pastor Doug bachelor president and
speaker of amazing
facts welcome listening friend to Bible
answers live this is Doug Bachelor and
I've got an amazing fact for you the
Leaning Tower of Pisa is a world famous
183t Bell Tower in Pisa Italy shortly
after construction began in
1173 the builders noticed the structure
was not perfectly level because of the
shallow foundation and silty soil
Architects believe there's really
nothing more they could do about the
slight l
therefore between a number of small Wars
and financial setbacks it took him
another 200 years to actually finish the
tower in the centuries that follow the
Tilt gradually increased until it was
leaning a precarious 15 ft off vertical
Center by 1990 the iconic structure was
at risk of toppling and closed to the
public during the next decade they spent
$40 million to slightly straighten the
Leaning Tower and reinforce the
foundation
eventually they deemed it safe enough to
reopen for turists to stand near it and
to enter the Crooked Monument you know
the Bible says you need to lay your
plans carefully before you build a tower
or others will mock stay with us friends
we're going to learn more as amazing
facts brings you this edition of Bible
answers live you're listening to Bible
answers live honest answers to your
Bible
[Music]
questions our phone lines are now open
if you have a Bible related question
call us at 1 800 God says that's 1 1800
7297 now let's join our host Pastor Doug
Bachelor and our co-host Pastor Jean
Ross well friends we're so glad that
you've tuned in for Bible answers live
it is a live International interactive
Bible study interactive because we
invite you to call in with your Bible
questions that number is 800 God says
because the Bible is our foundation for
these studies we use the word of God 800
God says that's 800 46372 N7 of course
it's a free phone call and um I guess
it's been they're kind of free
everywhere now aren't they just that
used to mean something anyway uh do have
lines wide open so give us a call 800
46372 N7 and I am Doug Bachelor my name
is Jean Ross good evening listening
friends and pass the Doug let's begin
the program with prayer dear father in
Heaven what a privilege to be able to
open up your word and study together we
want to ask your blessing upon this
program be with those listening and
guide us Lord into a clearer full
understanding of the Bible for we ask
this in Jesus name amen amen well Pastor
Dy open the program by talking about the
amazing uh leaning tower of pizza now
I've actually been there have you been
there I have but it's been I was 16
years old so it's been a long time ago I
when I went there I don't think they
actually allowed you to go in they were
doing renovations or something but it is
quite spectacular look at it and keep
man that's going to fall down all you
need is an earthquake and it's over and
yet it's been standing for a long time
it's amazing yeah they have earthquakes
around Italy but not necessarily that
part yeah I think when I went I was like
16 years old and that's been a few years
ago um I did go in you could go in it
back then and you have there's a lot of
steps that you climb up and that's the
tower that uh Legend tells us where
Galileo dropped two balls to see if they
would you know a small and a big one see
if they actually fell at the same speed
did some experiments
but um you know over the centuries it's
become iconic because so many people
mock they take pictures next to it and
they lean into it they act like they're
holding it up and and you know you just
think how in the world could they build
something that ornate and not know it
just wasn't level it's because they got
the foundation wrong and you know
there's a story a parable actually Jesus
tells in Luke 14 verse 28 for which of
you intending to build a tower does not
sit down first and count the C cost
whether or not he's going have enough to
finish it lest after he lays the
foundation he's not able to finish all
who see begin to mock him and say this
man began to build and was not able to
finish maybe I shouldn't mix my amazing
facts but I don't know if people know
that the the Washington Monument another
Tower they ran out of money before they
built it and uh there were years I think
40 years at one point where it was kind
of half buil because the government
could not get enough money to finish and
so there was a monument that everybody
mocked but even more important than that
Jesus talks about foundations and you
know the parable of the wise man and the
fool the wise man builds his house on a
rock the fool builds his house on the
sand problem with the Tower of Pisa is
it was sandy soil and they just couldn't
get a stable foundation and Jesus said
if you're going to have a successful
life you need a good foundation and the
the foundation he said is he that hears
these words of mine and does them the
word of God
must be the foundation for your life the
Bible is a rock you can build on and
when the storm comes your house will
stand friends what is guiding your world
viiew about what is truth and what is
right and what is wrong if it's anything
other than the Bible you're building on
the sand and we'd like to encourage you
to explore why the Bible has been the
bestselling book through history and why
it makes a wonderful foundation for your
life and for your faith we have a free
offer we like to make available tonight
we have an offer that RAR deals with the
Bible that is the foundation The Rock
upon which we build and we'll be happy
to send this to anybody who calls and
asks just call out a resource phone
number that number is 800 835 6747 you
can ask for the book called The Ultimate
resource the number again is 800 835
6747 we'll be happy to send you the book
about the Bible called the ultimate
resource and if you have a Bible
question our phone line here at the
studio this evening is 800 463
7297 that's 800-
46372 97 we're going to go to the phone
lines our first caller this evening is
Steve and he's listening in Oregon uh
Steve welcome to the
program hey how you doing this is
Stephen thanks for calling in your
question
tonight so um my friend and I have
started a Ministry on Facebook and we
it's called his feet Ministry and we're
just putting out some studies there and
stuff and we were doing a study on the
health message and one of the scriptures
that came back from somebody was Genesis
93 and I you want me to go ahead and
read it sure that'd be fine um yeah
Genesis 9:3 every moving thing that
lives shall be meat for you even as the
green herb have I given you all things
so the person was concerned that this
scripture said that God has given every
animal for us to eat and I was just kind
of I've never heard this one addressed
in in the health message so I was just
kind of wondering if you could give me
some thoughts on this all right well
first of all this is After the flood and
all the vegetation had been or nearly
all of it had been destroyed you
remember it was great celebration when a
Dove came back with a little olive leaf
in its mouth telling that things had
begun to sprout and to grow again and so
um then God had already specified Before
the Flood that there were clean animals
and they were unclean and So based on
this
specification they were free to eat
those things that were deemed clean and
so he said everything there were fish
they could eat there were animals they
could eat there were Birds they could
eat but they needed to be in the clean
category and all a person has to do is
use common sense and say I mean what
human in the world believes it's okay to
eat anything will you eat a starfish
would you eat a skunk would you you know
what I'm saying would you you eat
cockroaches and and so stuff like that
so
obviously God wasn't you know when he
said that he Saidi giving you permission
to eat things that um are in the
category from the earlier chapter about
the clean and the unclean and if
anyone's wondering what those are uh you
can find both the clean and the unclean
by the way we are all related to Noah
and so
um everybody I think should follow these
Health laws God specifies that the clean
animals go ahead appreciate you saying
that because that's those were kind of
my thoughts too and that's what I kind
of put out there but you know we are
dealing with a lot of people that don't
really have much Common Sense anymore in
the world today I I hope I'm not
offending anybody by saying that but
yeah I know what you mean um you know we
do have a free study guide and I'm sure
that uh you are aware of it but others
listening may not know and it's called
God's free health plan and it talks
about what the the Bible says are the uh
specifications for the clean and the
unclean animals the number to call to
receive that uh study guide is 800 835
6747 that is our resource phone uh phone
number and you can just ask for the
study guide called God's free health
plan that number is 8835
6747 we'll be happy to send that to
anybody who calls and
asks well thank you for your call
Stephen we're going to go to William who
is listening in New York William welcome
to the program
hello hey William you're on the air
thanks for calling thank you so much
Pastor Doug Bachelor how are you today
doing good good and good well my
question is that ever since that you
came out with the prophecy code it's
tremendous serious that you come out it
gives me a great Revelation where
actually I share with Believers and and
you talk tremendous stuff that's
actually biblical because I can know
this because I get a confirmation from
the spirit and during the seminar that
you teach I watch it maybe over 10 times
I don't get sick of tired watching it
because I know that God always revealing
me something new when you give the
message I heard it time but um every
ever since that you you talked in the
program and you said that uh actually
one day about the dead man of Lazarus so
I'm thinking in the seminar you're gonna
speak this and you never speak about the
question my question even though um the
Bible teaches us a a a godly man should
not
quarrel um I have had a a discussion on
another Bader and uh he was telling that
Jesus is not a God that can lie and I
said absolutely not so why will he told
a story about the rich man and Lazarus
and at the same time talking about the
tormenting that's going to happen and I
didn't want to debate with him too much
because I don't want to start a Strife
because you know when start a
Strife come to a place where it's not
edif edification of of in the spirit but
he's telling me why Jesus says this
Jesus is is telling the story and I said
this has to do with a symbolic reason I
know it has to be a symbolic it's a
parable metaphoric that actually he's
talking about things that we can learn
from can you be more specific even
though I never got to hear the the
answer to that question when you posted
on well let let me talk a little bit
about the the parable of the rich man
and
Lazarus um you find it by the way in
Luke 16: 19 and it's it says there is a
certain rich man clothed in purple fine
linen he feasted every day and a poor
beggar named Lazarus full of swords that
laid it his gate and people then it says
the rich man dies and U he goes to
torment Lazarus dies and he goes to
Abraham's bosom and the rich man asks
Lazarus Father Abraham if Lazarus can
bring him a drop of water to cool his
tongue well first of all I don't know
too many people that believe that the
sav
and the lost are going to be able to
talk to each other the saved are going
to talk to the people burning in Hell or
that a drop of water would cool a
person's tongue or that everybody that
is saved is going to Abraham's bosom
there's no other place in the Bible that
talks about Abraham's bosom so what
Jesus did here is he told a parable with
some Paradox in it it's it's obviously
an
illustration and he said that basically
the meaning of it is that the Jewish
nation was rich they had the truth they
were feasting on the truth the bread of
life the word of God and they had the
Gentiles Lazarus the Beggars around them
that were starving for the crumbs that
fell from their table but Jesus was
warning them that if they did not share
the word of God with others they might
find that when they die that they are
outside and the Gentiles are on the
inside now many of the disciples shared
the same thing they said many will come
from the East and the west and sit down
in the Kingdom with Abraham Isaac and
Jacob but the children of the Kingdom
meaning there could be some Jews that
will be on the outside because they
didn't care about the loss they did not
love their neighbor and there'll be
Gentiles on the inside so this is the
essence of his Parable and what Jesus
does is he says that Lazarus the Gentile
is in the Jewish heaven with Abraham and
the the rich man who represents the Jews
who did not believe they are in the
Pagan Jesus uses the word Hades they're
in the Greek place of torment and so
Christ is using a little bit of humor in
a paradox here to teach this Parable
it's not to be taken literally it's a
parable so um I do have a book I'll send
your free copy Stephen it's called the
rich man and Lazarus and all you've got
to do is call the resource number and we
will send you that book and we
appreciate your call the number call is
8835 6747 just ask for the book called
the rich man and Lazarus again that
number is 800 835
6747 May if you have a Bible question
would like to get your question on the
air this evening our phone line here to
the studio is 800
7297 800 463
7297 then we have Ron listening from
Arizona Ron welcome to Bible answers
live good evening um I had the privilege
of leading a man to Christ who was dying
and cancer and was unable to be baptized
and another Pastor told me that's not
good enough if he's not baptized he's
going to hell and needless to say that
upset me something terrible I don't
believe that but I wanted to get your
opinion well I would respectfully
disagree with the pastor that told you
that because uh Jesus led someone to
believe in him while he was hanging on
the cross you know that Thief that died
beside Christ and he said you will be
with me in Paradise
and uh that man did not come down from
the cross and go run and get baptized
and of course there's a lot of people in
the Old Testament before the practice of
baptism that will be in the Kingdom such
as Abraham Isaac and Jacob and so the
idea that you have to be baptized to be
saved it is a Christian right we teach
it Jesus did say go preach into all the
world baptize in the name of the father
Son and Holy Spirit the disciples did
say repent and be baptized but the idea
that you can't be saved without
baptism is like saying you can't love
someone without
marriage so you know we're we're not
saved by baptism we're saved by Christ
and by faith in him now if a person says
well I I know what the Bible says about
baptism and I want to accept Jesus but I
just I don't I don't want to get
baptized it's inconvenient well that's
dangerous that's Disobedience but if a
person's in a prison or they're in a in
a hospital and they're dying and they
come to Christ baptism will not be an
obstacle to to their salvation now
here's one more thought on that Ron was
Jesus
baptized uh well yeah all right was
Jesus baptized to wash away his
sin I can't answer that well no you know
the Bible says Jesus never sinned
correct correct all right so Jesus died
not for his sin but he died for our sin
Jesus was baptized not for his sin but
he was baptized in behalf of those who
could not be and they can get credit for
Christ's baptism Jesus will give them
credit for his own baptism just like he
gives us credit for his righteousness to
cover our
sin does that make sense yeah I
appreciate the person told me belongs to
a church which I've all mentioned
because you asked me not to I just
believe that they're they're just dead
wrong thank you so much brother God
bless you all right God bless and thanks
for your question Ron I'm just thinking
if we have a free offer that kind of
goes along baptism isn't necessary
that's right I think that book would be
ideal the number to call is um 800 835
6747 and you can just ask for the book
on baptism called baptism is it really
necessary we'll be happy to send that to
anybody who calls and asks and if you
would like to read the book online just
go to the Amazing Facts website just
amazingfacts.org you can type in the
little search bar baptism and uh I think
not only will you find the book but
you'll also find some sermons dealing
with that same subject so just a great
resource if you have a Bible question
the phone line is
7297 Joshua is listening in Orlando
Florida uh Joshua welcome to the
program hey guys how you good appreciate
your call you got hit hey Pastor duck
how you doing sir good to see good to
talk to you yeah glad you called in your
question yes sir so uh they said to keep
it under three minutes I Gotta Give a
Little Bit of back but basically I just
wanted uh your thoughts on this uh
question okay so basically I've been
researching I've been a Christian for a
while and reformed theology seems to be
very accurate uh to me and my question
is on uh unconditional uh election as
far as it also applies to the free will
now I'm not asking whether it's free
will or God's sovereignty I know the
answer is both and it's God's ways are
higher than ours but but I feel that I
hear pastors ignoring the reformed which
I feel is very backed up by scripture of
total depravity we're dead in sin filthy
rags is our righteousness none comes to
me unless the father draws him to the
sun right so we balance that but then I
hear you know you hear a pastor saying
you know God leaves it up to you you
know he stands at the door and knocks
and you know the scriptures about Jesus
didn't didn't you know heal them because
of their belief like he it depends upon
us right that God is uh waiting on us to
respond but that seems to be
unbiblical uh in my view and I just
wanted to know is that something that
you know semantics that I'm just being
critical on and I should just you know
not be well upset about it or whatever
you know what I mean I think so you know
Joshua you're asking the big questions
in the Bible the the great the iians
have grappled over the you know the Free
Will and the sovereignty and the you
know Calvinism and uh I'm of the belief
based on a lot of scripture at least I
think that you know I'm basing this on
scripture that God loves us God draws us
he takes the initiative to save us if we
are saved he gets the glory but because
you cannot have love without Choice
otherwise we're just automatic robots
you know where it's God may as well make
a tape player that says I love you he
really does give us a freedom to choose
and while he knows the future he is not
making us choose him otherwise why would
he tell so many prophets choose you this
day who will you will serve or turn ye
turn ye why will you die um and there's
just a number of cases where he sends
Messengers that are appealing for the
listeners to make a decision like Elijah
on Mount kmer how long will you halt
between two decisions if it's all
predestined why do they use that
language inviting us to
choose um Jesus said to some disciples
follow me and they forsook everything
and followed him he said to the Rich
Young Ruler follow me but he couldn't
because he was rich and he just made the
decision not to and so I think a lot of
people don't realize that you know we
are making Eternal
decisions uh regarding our destiny if
we're lost it's not God's fault because
he did not pre-program us
correctly it wouldn't make sense sense
for him to then punish us for not doing
what we were incapable of
doing you know what I'm
saying right and that that my question
because it just seems that the Bible
backs up that you are incapable of
choosing that inless God enables Us by
his Spirit but it almost seems like it's
more watered down to like wooing instead
of how the Greek in that drawing of
Jesus he literally means unless the
father drags them you know draws them to
him uh to you know him then he can't
even come to the son none can come into
unless the father drags him literally
you know well I don't think it's
dragging anymore than you know a husband
takes his wife by the hair and drags her
to a cave I think he draws us right the
Bible tells us with the loving kindness
he has drawn
us and so um yeah I I believe you know
what I've got a book I'll send you
that's got a lot more scripture than we
can share in just a few minutes here and
it's can a save man choose to be lost
and it's really a good book got a great
study in it it's it's a quick read but
it's got lots of studies and it's free
and matter of fact you may want to read
it online tonight you can probably find
it at the amazing facts Free Library
just go to the amazingfacts website
amazingfacts.org or you can call our
resource phone number and we'll be happy
to send this to you Joshua or anybody
wanting to learn more about the subject
the number is 8835 6747 you can ask for
the book can a saved man choose to be
lost that number is 800 8356
747 our next call is uh Michael
listening in Miami Florida Michael
welcome to the
program hello Pastor Doug Pastor Ross hi
um hello my question is uh steming out
of two scriptures is Genesis 9 verse 20
through2 and also scripture at Leviticus
20 uh you know Genesis 9:25 talk about
when Noah was drunk and uh I believe it
was hem that saw yeah hem saw the
nakedness of his father and told us to
brother out and you know sh and Jacob
covered him up but then the thing is
when Noah woke up he said cursed be
Canan um and I guess growing up I always
thought that the scripture was just
blatantly saying that ham saw Noah in
the nude because he was drunk but when I
looked at back to the Scripture it says
it just simply says that he Noah was
uncovered within his tent and that
reminded me of uh Leviticus 20 verse 11
it says and the man that life of his
father's wife hath uncovered his
father's
nakedness um since both Leviticus and
Genesis are written by Moses I was just
assuming that maybe it was the same
literary uh uh semantics if you will in
that perhaps what Genesis 9 was actually
saying happened was that Noah was drunk
and while he was drunk that Canaan uh
since he was the one that actually got
cursed slept with Noah's wife I'm not
sure if I'm you know being too much the
stick with semantics here or is that you
think you think it's a fair reading yeah
no I understand what you're saying it is
a difficult passage the way I have
understood it is that uh Noah being
drunk was
uncovered um I don't think that means
that ham or Canan slept with her father
I think what happens is ham came into
the tent with his son they saw Dad and
Grandpa was drunk they went out and they
kind of mocked him to others and the
ible says you should respect your father
and mother and so a curse fell upon them
for being disrespectful now the reason I
say that it says Shem and japheth took a
garment they put it on their shoulders
and they went backward and covered the
nakedness of their father so the next
verse makes it pretty clear Noah was
naked and they didn't want to look upon
out of respect the nakedness of their
father and or be disrespectful and so uh
they they did it that way whereas him
came in and he gazed and he mocked and
probably described it to others in the
uh in the village there that's the you
know when I look at different
commentaries that's the the take that I
get from that and then you know he
basically broke the Commandment about
honoring your father now it doesn't
justifi Noah being drunk but they should
not have responded that
way right I was always just like um it's
a little confused because it says ham
saw his nakedness but then when Noah
woke up he said cursed be Canan um
yeah I think that it's because because
after ham saw it he went out and
obviously he told
others that's how they knew he saw it
and I think that maybe his son Canan uh
was you know mocking do you remember the
story in the Bible where Ishmael was
mocking Isaac when Isaac they had a
feast for Isaac and it was pretty
serious and finally Abraham sent Hagar
and Ishmael away so I think something
like that was going on here as well
hey I appreciate your call Michael we uh
we do have a couple of more lines open I
don't know if we've got a time for a
break we got one minute tell you what
instead of taking um another call and
cutting them short right now stand by if
you're on the line we're going to get
you your call and we do have a couple of
line still open let me give you that
number again 800
46372 N7 also keep in mind that uh not
all but most of the books and the free
re resources that we offer to send you
from amazing facts that have oh we got
hundreds of studies on hundreds of
subjects uh you can read many of them
for free you can download them as PDFs
and put them in your Kindle reader um at
the amazingfacts website so when you go
to amazingfacts.org
you'll end up seeing that uh there's a
tab that says Free Library click on that
and you'll see the u a plethora of
studies there's also a website where you
can enter online into some personal
Bible studies it's called Bible Universe
just go to Bible universe.com I think if
you type in Bible universe. org you'll
get there just as well and a long time
ago we registered a number of these
domains to make sure that uh people
could find them easily Bible Universe
sign up for the studies there and you
will boy I'll tell you it'll change your
life don't go away friends we're going
to have a quick break so that our other
Affiliates can do a station ID coming
back to your phone calls with more Bible
questions
[Music]
stay tuned Bible answers live will
return in a
[Music]
moment find out what the critics are
raving about top Scholars and
theologians from around the country come
together to reveal the hidden history of
the Book of
Revelation with powerful reenactments
and incredible visual effects this
95-minute Masterpiece brings to life the
Book of Revelation like never before
Revelation is no longer a mystery get
your copy today visit iTunes or AF
bookstore.com
in 6 days God created the heavens and
the Earth for thousands of years man has
worshiped God on the seventh day of the
week now each week millions of people
worship on the first day what happened
why did God create a day of rest does it
really matter what day we worship who is
behind this great shift discover the
truth behind God's law and how it was
changed visit sabbathtruth.com
Can't Get Enough amazing facts Bible
study you don't have to wait until next
week to enjoy more truth filled
programming visit the amazing facts
media library at aftv.org at AFV org you
can enjoy video and audio presentations
as well as printed material all free of
charge 24 hours a day 7 days a week
right from your computer or mobile
device visit aftv.org
[Music]
every Bible question you have answered
moves you one step closer to the
fullness of God's will for your life so
what are you waiting for get the answers
you need for a Fuller richer more
confident life you're listening to Bible
answers
live this broadcast is a previously
recorded episode if you'd like answers
to your Bible related questions on the
air please call us next Sunday between 7
p.m. and 8:00 p.m. Pacific time to
receive any of the Bible resources
mentioned in this evening's program call
800 835
6747 once again that's 800 8356
747 now let's join pastors Doug Bachelor
and Jean Ross for more Bible answers
live welcome back listening friends and
for those who tuned in along the way
this is Bible answers live and we are
taking Bible questions if you've got a
phone you can call in with a question
you might have a radio and not a phone
it is possible here's the number
8463 7297
I am Doug Bachelor my name is John Ross
and uh Pastor Doug I think we're ready
to go straight to the phone lines the
next caller is Mark and he is listening
in um let's see Damascus Massachusetts I
believe Mark welcome to the
program good evening it's actually
Damascus Maryland Maryland Maryland
okay I'd like to revisit the uh question
of the subject of free will all right
let's do it it's my understanding that
the reason why one reason why there is
evil and sin in the world is because we
have free will to choose right from
wrong God gave us that Free Will so that
we would not be become programmed
automatons and that we The Cho Choice
the right choice would have value my
question is uh after the tribulation
after the second coming during the
Millennium we will have new bodies and
we will be uh in a new world my question
is uh will we have free will once we get
our new bodies I believe so because if
we're going to love God we need a free
will um I believe the angels have a free
will and that's why some followed God
and some chose to follow Lucifer they
were able to choose and the angels that
follow Lucifer were cast
out yeah because they they as I
understand it uh uh there is no there
will be no sin and no suffering no evil
in the Millennium and uh
I'm just was curious if we will still
have free will or not right yeah so we
we'll still have free will I believe
because we love the Lord sin will never
rise up again and you can read about
that in the book naom sin will not rise
up the second time or Affliction will
not rise up the second time forever
Jesus will have the scars in his hand
that remind us about the cost of sin and
we have this life to choose whether or
not we want to love and serve God and so
we will be thoroughly settled in the
truth truth in our choice and love for
God a man and woman can date and they
can choose each other to get married
they make a covenant they love each
other they're committed and they can be
married for you know a hundred
years at least back in the days of the
Patriarchs and U they don't they've
always got their free choice but they've
settled on their Covenant to each other
and they love each other you see what
I'm saying so free choice but the free
choice doesn't mean you're going to
always choose to
sin but
because the Millennium will there there
will be no sin or suffering and during
the Millennium that that nons sin will
be written to our hearts yeah well we
will still have free will well of course
we still have free will because like I
said you can't love God if we don't have
a free will it ceases to be love love
must be freely given otherwise it's just
a computer program that is saying I love
you God I love you God that's
meaningless to God he wants us that
clears it up for me to choose him
because yeah please send for that book
we offered earlier on can a save man
shoes to be lost it'll also deal with
this issue mark thank you for your call
our next call is um let's see Cliff is
listening from Florida Cliff welcome to
the
program hi Pastor hi Cliff thanks for
calling hi yes um my question is based
on a sermon that and correct me if I'm
wrong but I didn't catch the whole
sermon and I don't even remember what
the topic was about but I thought that
I'd heard you mention unfallen world
in the sermon and I I didn't catch the
whole thing so I was trying to ask if
you
believed biblically based
um if so where are you getting it from
in the Bible that do you believe that
there are unfallen
worlds um out there and do you mean
unfallen worlds that are inhabited by
people or just unfallen worlds like
unfallen planets that will one day be
for us all right good question I I've
got a message I shared a few years ago
that's on YouTube and it's got many
thousands of hits on a lot of people
have passed it around and I think it's
talks about is there life on other
planets and U I say yes and I start with
a very simple premise God talks about
angels angels are alive they're
ministering Spirits um there's a number
of scriptures where the Lord talks about
uh making
worlds and you can read is it Hebrews 1
ver2 Pastor Ross where it says through
whom he made the worlds mhm uh now do
they have people on them no I don't
think so because on this planet God made
Man In His Image we are unique in many
respects but does he have life on other
planets that is sinless well there's a
scripture where Jesus shares a parable
about a man who's got a hundred sheep
but one goes astray he leaves the 99
safe in the fold and he comes looking
for the one lost sheep well I think that
this world was a lost world after ad
fell Christ came to this world to save
us but you just remember that Jesus is
eternal God is eternal space is infinite
the idea that we are it is sort of a a
you know it's kind of an an egomaniac
idea that there's no other intelligent
life out there but us I don't think the
others have sinned I think they're
unfallen I mean the life that you think
might be out there do you think that
that life but Earth is um exclusive in a
sense that we are the only ones made in
created in His image the other worlds
would not have life created in His image
you know I think that when we start to
speculate about what the creatures on
the unfallen worlds are like I believe
there's other intelligent creatures that
God has made that worship him you know
you you could start going through all
the strange things you see on Star Wars
or Star Trek and trying to imagine what
they look like they always look like
people in strange makeup but
I think we can't even imagine the Bible
says the things that God has prepared
for those that love him but I guess one
follow question I may the same question
if that's the case when God KCK Satan
out of heaven then I I always wonder why
then why do you think KCK him out of
Heaven he would have pass him down to
earth our world versus one of these
other worlds well the the time when
Satan was cast down to our world was
after Adam and Eve sinned and you read
about that in Revelation 12 where it
says that the devil was cast to the
earth when Adam and Eve sinned the Bible
says in Romans 6 whoever you obey that's
whose servants you are and originally
God gave Dominion of the world to Adam
and Eve when they chose to listen to and
obey the devil instead of God they
handed over Dominion of the world to the
enemy that's why Jesus Calls the devil
the prince of this world and so U and
you know we do have a study guide that
talks about that that will give you a
little more information talks about the
fall of Lucifer
and it's did God create a devil we'll
send you a free copy Cliff if you'd like
that did God create a
devil yeah the number to call is 800 835
6747 you can ask for the study guide
called did God create a devil and we
also have another book Pastor Doug as
you mentioning uh talking about these
other worlds called who are the sons of
God that's and we'll be happy to send
that to you Cliff or anybody it talks
about uh the inhabitants of these uh
unfallen worlds what does the Bible say
about it and uh what scripture
references are there it's a great
resource just call and ask who are the
sons of God is what the book's called
and the number is
6747 and if you have a Bible question
the phone line here to the studio is
297 one more time 800
7297 our next call is LZ listening from
Orlando Florida L welcome to the
program thank thank you how you guys are
doing doing good and your question
tonight um my question is um I'm
struggling uh on the when the Sabbath
starts whether it's evening or morning
um when I when I first learned about the
Sabbath um when I found out about the
evening I just wanted to find out which
was the truth so that I don't have to
keep thinking about it because I keep uh
stressing about it and then I came to
the persuasion that it's in the morning
and uh couple uh just two examples real
quick is that like in the beginning in
the in Genesis uh in the evening in the
morning or the first day I would read
that as the evening came and then the
morning came and then that's the first
day and then also like in the
crucifixion the way the evening and the
morning were used I just keep it to me I
just read it as if the evening um if the
morning is the beginning of the Sabbath
morning to morning I just need some help
with this yeah the the Bible has a
statement that makes it pretty clear it
says well and first of all for anyone
that's listening there's a lot of
Christians that are kind of
rediscovering the fourth Commandment in
the Ten Commandments it says remember
the Sabbath a lot of blessings I read
about people that are even taking the
Sabbath from their electronics and
saying boy we need a rest they get we
get tied down we have uh you know
there's so much stress and anxiety I
think the top medications all are
related to stress and um people are
struggling to sleep and a lot of it can
be traced back to not taking time off to
rest the way God commands it does say in
the Bible from even unto even will you
celebrate your sabbaths and then again
and where is it Pastor Ross in the New
Testament at even when the sun did set
it is in the gospel of Mark I'm pretty
sure maybe it's Mark chapter 2 they
brought all the people to him um yeah
that's Mark chapter 1:32 132 Mark 132
and so there's several verses that make
it clear that the the Sabbath would
begin at sundown and even your orthodox
Jews around the world they celebrate the
Sabbath when the Sun goes down now sun
down varies you know depending on what
time zone you're in but today it's
really easy to figure that out you've
even got an app that will beep you
before the Sabbath begins give you 15
minute warning or something does that
help a little bit uh
LZ um what the the verse you said about
the evening to evening you should
celebrate your savath I I came to learn
that that that verse was just only for
that specific feast and what helps a
little bit uh is the When you mention
the Jews because you know if if
tradition is being passed down since the
beginning you know it would make sense
that they're still keeping that that way
yeah didn't think about it that way they
they always believe that a day began and
ended at sundown and one more evidence
of course is Jesus when he's crucified
it says that uh the Sabbath Drew on he
he died he was executed like 9 in the
morning they took him him off the cross
at about 4 in the afternoon and they
wanted to finish embalming his body
before the Sabbath began and that would
be at
sundown and so uh they said we won't
come back until Sunday morning because
they wanted to wait and let him he Jesus
even kept the Sabbath and his death you
might say so uh um I'm sorry what but
what makes me struggle a lot is that
when when Joseph uh was able to take
Jesus's body it says that evening
already came so I'm assuming it's it's a
whole new day I feel like I'm struggling
with how I'm interpreting the evening
when it comes to when it starts within
the evening if that makes any sense well
yeah Joseph came and got his body off
the cross before Sund down and he was
with the women and they stopped and you
can read there in Luke that they uh put
his body in the Tomb and they went home
and rested according to the Sabbath and
Jesus died before Sundown so um you know
we do have a book we can send you that
talks about that well we have a study
guide and that talks about well let me
see um we got several books but to
specifically answer what you're asking
would it be uh what's the best oh hey
you can you get online
laws yeah yeah here's a website that's
got some great stuff Sabbath truuth just
go to sabbathtruth.com it's the most
popular website on the internet on the
Sabbath it's got all the verses for you
right there and anybody if you want to
know more about the subject a lot of
people people are rediscovering the
Sabbath sabbathtruth.com and if you'd
like to receive a study guide dealing
with it called The Lost day of History
talking about the Sabbath we'll be happy
to send it to anybody who calls and asks
the number is 800
83567 47 and again you can ask for the
study guide called The Lost day in
history and we'll be happy to send that
to anybody who calls let's see our next
caller is uh Spencer listening from Los
Angeles Spencer welcome to the
program hello hi you you're on the air
hi hi this is Miss Spencer from
California and I wanted to ask the
question about women pastors when it
speaks of in the Bible that women are
to be he suffers a woman not to teach
but for a woman to be silent and not
have the authority over men why are
people ordaining women
pastors well there are people doing a
lot of things that aren't biblical that
would be of course my first answer I
want to make it clear that I do think
that uh God calls women to various
aspects of ministry there are women
prophets in the bible and you've got
women like Priscilla the wife of Aquilla
that are giving Bible studies um but
what you don't find in the Bible is
there is no example from Genesis to
Revelation in the Bible of a woman
serving in the capacity of a priest or a
pastor or an
elder and so these were rol
that were God designed that men should
be the priest leaders of the family
now you know men and women could be part
of the priesthood but the job of the
women in the priesthood was very
different from the job of the men only
the men would sacrifice no example in
the woman I'm sorry no example in the
Bible of a woman being uh ordained as a
king there's no example of a woman
offering a sacrifice the the men were to
be the priests for the family but there
were women the daughters of Aaron matter
of fact Elizabeth was called a daughter
of Aaron and there were roles for them
to serve in the sanctuary too but they
did not do the um the public teaching
and they did not do the the
sacrifice you still there lord said he
yes such as a woman not to to keep
silent he doesn't mean to just keep
silent and say nothing just don't have
authority over the man yeah I I believe
that's correct um there's many cases of
women that were speaking in church and
they were filled with the spirit you've
got henah who she went to the temple and
she prayed and she you know praised God
and then you got Anna when Jesus was a
baby uh she was in the temple and she
spoke and so it wasn't Paul I don't
think is making a statement first of all
don't ever build a Doctrine on one verse
so if it seems a little outrageous and
find out compared to other verses uh so
I don't think God is saying that a woman
was never to speak in church I think
that the Bible was telling us that in
that Corinthian Church uh sometimes the
women were uh asking their husbands
questions and Paul is saying look you
need to talk together about these when
you get home the women also sat
separately from the men in many of these
services and they were calling over to
their husbands and it was I guess
creating a
Ruckus so that's probably what was going
on there and um I've got a book that I
can send you a free copy Carol I'm sorry
Spencer or um anyone else that would
like one it's called women in Ministry
women in Ministry we'll be happy to send
that to you our next caller is oh
actually the number I forgot to give the
number it's 800 835 6747 that is our
resource phone number and you can ask
for the book called woman in Ministry
we'll be happy to send that to you Miss
Spencer or anybody who calls and asks uh
next call is Lisa listening in
Orangeville California uh Lisa you on
the
air yes hi hi thanks for calling yeah um
first just wanted to say thank you for
your program it's been very helpful and
a big blessing I'm sure to many people
well thank you and yeah and I wanted to
get some clarity to make sense on
there's you know like if you're single
and it says if you if you got to be
willing to work to eat okay and then
there's the other part of you can't
serve both God and money right so can
you
please clarify all that for me or me
yeah well when Jesus says that you can't
serve God in Mammon or money he's not
saying don't work for money he's saying
don't let it be your God and of course
you know Paul says that the love of
money is the root of all evil right and
so again he's saying not money is evil
because Paul you know he went through
Asia and picked up a big offering to
bring to Jerusalem so he thought that
there was a purpose for money um and
Paul worked and he got paid Paul was a
tent maker and so when Paul said if you
won't work you shouldn't eat there the
church in the early days had a fund to
take care of the orphans and the widows
and then Paul actually goes through some
guidelines about which people would
qualify to receive of the the church um
assistance program that they had and you
had to be a widow over 60 that was in
good reputation and you know sometimes
they they couldn't uh earn if they were
younger he said that they should either
um you know work and
contribute uh and or you know uh get
married again something that Paul said
so um I don't know if that does that
help answer your question Lisa yeah very
well yes thank you all right thanks so
much our next call is Ry listening from
Michigan Ray welcome to Bible answers
live hello sir how you doing doing good
how can we help you
today uh I have a question uh
when uh Delilah found out the secret of
Samson's strength of course we we know
it wasn't really his hair it was God
that gave him the strength right but uh
did um did she cut off his hair or did
she call for the barber and he cut off
his hair well if I remember correctly
she why he slept she called for somebody
to come and that would be you know what
judges um if TR remember what chapter in
judges that's in it's one of the last
chapters but I'm pretty sure she called
for somebody that came and uh cut off
his hair and and she kind of put him to
sleep in her lap and U said the
Philistines be upon you um let me see
here oh I've just about got it uhhuh
yeah here we go she lulled him to sleep
on her knees and called for a man who
had him and had him shave off the Seven
Locks of his head so she had one of the
servants that was hiding in the wings
somewhere sneak out when he went to
sleep and they had a sharp Implement to
snip off his locks and the hair of
course was a symbol of his Covenant to
God because he was a Nazarite from his
youth so yeah God gave him his Spirit
but when he gave away the secret of his
Covenant he lost his power but when his
hair grew back and he prayed he got his
power back again and of course his last
prayer he put uh put out his arms and
brought down the house yes he did yes he
did so that tells us God can forgive I
guess he destroyed more Philistines then
than than he did before you know this is
one of the stories in the Bible Ry where
Samson is even a type of Christ the last
Act of his life was one of sacrifice he
stretched out his arms like Jesus
stretched out his arms and through his
death it says he killed more enemies
through his death than he did in his
life and Christ did more to Deliver Us
From The Enemy by his death and he was a
sacrifice that stretched out his hands
and so we believe we'll see Samson in he
in heaven and uh he'll probably have his
hair back then too and his eyes
but um he's mentioned in Hebrews 11
among the faithful so I think that's a
good a good indicator and thank you for
your call Ray good question who do we
have lined up next we have Mark
listening in uh Michigan Mark welcome to
the
program thank you for your radio
Ministry it's a tremendous blessing to
the community well thank you it's a
privilege um so here's my question uh
about 25 years ago maybe around
1992 a medical doctor asked a young
couple would they like their newborn
infant to have a
microchip or a nano chip implanted into
their
baby uh Flash Forward to today a young
lady uh wants to go the extra step we're
moving towards a cashless
society and now instead of paying at the
register with her phone using Apple pay
or Samsung pay or Android pay she wants
to have a procedure done where she can
have a type of microchip Nano chip
embedded into her hand so she can just
wave her hand at the register instead of
her
phone that being with all her finan
information embedded into the chip
that's embedded into her hand sorry
let's turn it into a
question huh let's turn this into a
question the question is is there any
scriptural uh guidance wisdom advice
that would be able to have helped the
young couple make the decision when
approached by the doctor 25 years ago or
this young lady today as to whether they
should be doing that all right I I think
I understand what you're asking um
personally I think it would be going
uh I think it'd be going beyond the
limits of privacy when if the government
were to embed your body physically with
some kind of ID it kind of reminds me of
what the Nazis did in tattooing uh
people in their prison of War Camp um
but uh you we all know about the mark of
the beast in the hand of the forehead I
do not believe the mark of the beast is
a
microchip um we had our dogs got a
microchip when we adopted them you can't
help it they they do it to all the pets
now so they can scan them and find them
and we did an amazing fact a couple
weeks ago about someone who lost a cat
in California ended up in Canada how it
got 2,000 miles away is a mystery we'll
have to ask the cat but it was the
microchip that helped him find his way
home so there are some advantages to
these things but um I personally
wouldn't want to do that I think your
body is a temple of the Holy Spirit you
should avoid you know having the
government put uh embed your body with
ID you can carry a card um but it is not
the mark of the
beast U the mark of the beast it tells
us is the opposite of having the law of
God in your heart or in your hand or in
your forehead you can read in
Deuteronomy chapter 6 where Moses said
he that hears these words of mine and
does them um were to hide God word in
our heart we're to have it as frontlets
between our eyes we are to tie it on our
hand so between the eyes on the hand
that's having the law of God that's the
Seal of God Thy word I have hidden in my
heart the mark of the beast is when you
have the laws of the Beast and you'll
obey the Beast and worship the beast in
your hand or in your forehead means in
your actions is in your hand between the
eyes is in your forehead that means in
your thoughts um so I I know we're
seeing more and more computer technology
being used to govern the buying and
selling and these things Mark like the
chips may be used to govern buying and
selling but it is not the mark of the
beast hey we will send you a lesson if
you want to know about that about what
is the mark of the beast and just call
the uh resource line that number 800 835
6747 that's 800 8356 747 our next caller
if we have time is Carol list Oakland
car we have just a few more
minutes Carol you there thank you thank
you um I guess my question summed up is
what role does you United States play in
the end times my daughter heard a sermon
by a pastor and he said because the
United States is not mentioned like the
bear Russia and those other countries
that are going to descend on Israel he
felt that we would be destroyed before
that happened and I wondered what your
thoughts were on that all right Carol
I'm GNA have to give you sort of a quick
answer here um we have a message online
for free on YouTube it's called the USA
in Prophecy you just type in Doug
Bachelor USA in Prophecy or a free study
Amazing Facts website that's
amazingfacts.org look for the USA in
Prophecy it is in Prophecy friends and
those things for told there are coming
soon look forward to studying together
again next week
thank you for listening to today's
broadcast we hope you understand your
Bible even better than before Bible
answers live is produced by amazing
facts a faith-based Ministry located in
Sacramento California
amazing facts began in
1965 with a god inspired concept hello
this is Joe Cruz on the amazing facts
broadcast facts which affect you each
radio broadcast would begin with an
amazing fact from science nature or
history followed by a bible message that
touched the hearts of listeners from
every Walk of Life the program was an
instant success and the ministry soon
began expanding to include Bible lessons
in 1986 amazing facts added the medium
of Television to its growing Outreach
efforts offering Soul winning
Evangelistic messages for viewers around
the world in 1994 Pastor Doug Bachelor
assumed leadership of the ministry
adding the Bible answers live call-in
radio program and new ministry TV
program programs began airing on
multiple networks around the world for
50 years the driving vision of amazing
facts has been the Bold proclamation of
the Everlasting gospel and with a team
of evangelists circling the globe and
thousands of men and women being trained
through the amazing fact Center of
evangelism program AFCO the ministry is
helping God's Church see a Rich Harvest
of
souls amazing facts God's m message our
mission if you'd like to enhance your
study of God's word visit our website at
www.amazingfacts.org
and sign up for our free Bible study
course and make sure to check out our
online bookstore at AF bookstore.com
which offers thousands of inspiring
books DVDs and more to help you get the
most out of God's word to take advantage
of the offers you've heard on this
broadcast call us at 800 835
6747 or visit our website at
amazingfacts.org did you enjoy this
program make sure to tell your family
and friends tune in next time for more
Bible answers live honest and accurate
answers to your Bible questions